so this will change the fate for
thousands of families all across the
country so how are those here locally
feeling about it madison kimbrough spoke
to some parents along with planned
parenthood she's in the newsroom for us
yeah we heard from both sides this
afternoon but one thing was universal
and that's that this decision has
changed the course of history forever
it's hard to kind of say that we're
moving forward
when
at this point they're having abortion
laws being a mother it should be up to
that woman's choice
she nobody should feel obligated to take
on that role because it is not an easy
role dre mafi and alexis mcveigh
enjoying a friday afternoon with their
families here at the park but at the
same time both are at a standstill due
to the recent overturn of roe v wade as
now a ban on abortion rights for
families has been enacted in some states
we're not really focused on the right
things
we're getting confused of human rights
and
basic rights and i don't think they're
the same however henderson mother
crystal gardener says she doesn't have
an issue with this ruling as she
believes life starts at conception i
have seven of my own children i've had
several miscarriages throughout my life
i know that can be hard for people
to raise families to have children to
not want that responsibility but there's
always somebody that does those at
planned parenthood taking action and
speaking out and locally members want
nevadans to know that abortion is still
legal in our state we will be a safe
state abortion will still continue to be
legal planned parenthood health centers
will remain open
and will be you know ready and willing
to accommodate patients from across the
nation
and with that statement from harmon it
furthers the concern for strained health
care in our state as planned parenthood
says many will come to nevada for
medical help but the question lies will
we have enough staffing and supply to
accommodate in the newsroom madison
kimbrough live local now